[Musique]
bon écoute et si la manière dont je suis
habillé si ce que je tient dans la main
et si ma façon de parler ne suffisent
pas vous alerter sur le genre de choses
que vous allez voir
alors je ne sais pas ce qu'il fera ce
que je sais c'est qu'il nous reste plus
que trois secondes avant d'en découvrir
bien plus 2 on vous aura prévenu sort du
chan moi aussi je travaille ici
bienvenue dans mon bureau
tu m'as dit que tu étais opératrice
téléphoniques aux urgences oui je t'aime
anti j'assouvis absolument tous les
fantasmes et ses besoin de quelqu'un
pour m'aider à nettoyer et être mon body
guard serait kevin costner et moi ou non
kevin costner se prend une balle à la
fin tu me fais confiance
combien tu payes par mois un peu ta
copine à dominatrice et a longtemps
était en quelque sorte amoureux une
amitié amoureuse quelque chose d'assez
fusion c'est compliqué ça q
poumon droit qu être dominatrice c'est
que sexuel la fac n'attend pas les
dominatrices alors qu'en fait cette
libère de l'ain dites moi ce qui vous a
mais en fait je viens pas vraiment pour
moi c'est pour mon nez excusez moi je
n'ai pas très bien d aller c'est plus
pour moi c'est pour mon mari
[Musique]
je suis pas fait pour ce qui vient de se
passer des plus courageux qu'est ce que
tu veux
ce que tu fais avec moi c'est super quoi
pourquoi tu me racontes jamais rien
parce que si je te disais ce que nous
allons faire avant de le faire tu ne
ferais jamais ça lui